a young man returns from a trip and
finds a suitcase with a twisted man
inside who has the ability to spit out
gold coins every time he feels pain
today on similar recapped i'll show you
the man in the suitcase
the story begins with a boy who has just
arrived in the city he's at the airport
waiting for his suitcase to be delivered
at that moment someone sends him a
message asking if he has arrived to
which the boy named justin replies
affirmatively but he also says that he
had a problem with his girlfriend since
she just left him and that his dad got
mad at him the friend asked justin why
his girlfriend left him and he replies
that it was because of school
at that moment the machine that brings
the suitcases stops and suddenly ejects
a black suitcase justin approaches and
decides to take the suitcase running
away right after when justin leaves the
airport the machine starts to work again
bringing a suitcase similar to the one
that justin took justin gets in his car
and drives home and on the way he
receives a message from his girlfriend
saying that she will come to his house
tomorrow to pick up her stuff
justin gets distracted and ends up
dropping the phone in the car and as a
consequence the phone dials his
ex-girlfriend who answers after a few
seconds she asked justin why he called
her reminding him that they're over
justin gets angry and picks up the phone
to hang up but just at that moment the
ex-girlfriend asks him if he's on drugs
justin tells her that he doesn't have to
answer that and the ex-girlfriend tells
him if their relationship ended because
of him
since she wants someone who's highly
motivated and not someone like him who
is doing poorly in his studies justin
tells her that studying is not easy to
which the ex replies that this is not an
excuse and that she's going to hang up
the call then justin gets home and puts
a suitcase near the door he goes to the
kitchen and grabs something to eat
justin goes to his room to study smoke a
little and watch adult channels on tv
after a few minutes justin sees out of
the corner of his eye that his suitcase
is moving and then he hears someone
calling for help from the inside justin
laughs and starts to say that it's not
funny because he thinks it's a joke but
the voice inside the suitcase tells him
that it's not a joke and please help him
justin gets scared and decides to put
the suitcase on the floor he opens it to
see what's inside and realizes that
there's a twisted man in the suitcase
the man tells him to help him settle his
head because he can't speak well like
that
justin gets scared takes a stick and
uses it to turn the man's head when he
sees justin the man asks him to please
not hit him with that stick so justin
puts it down and asks him what this is
all about the man tells him that he
offended someone dangerous and that is
why he's in that situation
then he says he needs help to get out of
the suitcase and justin offers to take
him to a hospital the man says they
can't help him in a hospital but justin
replies that he knows a friend who had
an accident and they were able to help
him in the hospital and starts talking
about how well his friend is doing after
that the man interrupts him and tells
him that he's suffering a lot in there
so he must help him quickly
justin apologizes and tries to close the
suitcase to take him to the hospital
however the man tells him not to take
him there because if he does the people
who did that to him will find him justin
gets scared when he finds out that there
are people after the man since he
doesn't want any trouble
but the man tells him that if he helps
him get out of there no one will know
what happened there and he'll just leave
justin decides to help him and starts to
pull his foot to get him out of there so
the man begins to suffer a lot then
suddenly the man spits out a gold coin
and justin manages to catch it justin is
rather surprised and the twisted man
explains that he has a strange condition
that causes gold coins to be expelled
from his body every time he feels pain
he tells him to help him get out of
there and that all the coins he gets in
the process will be given to him as a
reward for helping him however justin
decides to close the suitcase and takes
it to his room
where he sits on his bed and thinks
about what he will do with the man he
falls asleep for a moment and has a
nightmare where he dreams of someone
putting him in a suitcase and that some
men arrive to shoot him when he wakes up
he realizes that it was a nightmare and
then he takes the coin and asks the
dealer if the coin is valuable the
dealer tells him that it's an important
gold coin and they'll give him 270 for
it so justin accepts the deal and takes
the money then justin goes to see his
friend the one he was messaging before
and tells him about the coin he just
sold the friend tells him that he should
have asked for more money and that next
time he should call him before doing
that kind of deal the friend asked
justin where he found the coin and
justin proceeds to tell him everything
that happened with the twisted man the
friend doesn't believe him and makes fun
of him by saying that he's a liar that
does not want to tell the truth because
he doesn't want to share the money with
him justin tells his friend to go to his
house so he can see it with his own eyes
so they both go
and when they're about to enter justin's
ex-girlfriend comes out of the house
she was there to get her stuff as she
had said she tells justin that he's sick
and that she's already seen what he has
in his room
justin tells her that it's not what it
looks like and invites her and his
friend to come into the house to explain
what is happening so they all enter and
see the twisted man the ex-girlfriend
asked justin what he did to which he
replies that he did nothing since he
just found the man like that she tells
him that they should take him out of the
suitcase because it seems that he's
suffering a lot justin and his
ex-girlfriend decide to try to get the
man out of the suitcase but in the
process the man begins to spit many
coins out of his mouth when justin's
friend sees this he asks justin and his
ex to talk alone for a minute then he
tells him that she'd take advantage of
that man and become millionaires justin
tells him that they shouldn't do that
since the man is suffering and needs
their help but the friend insists to
first take advantage of the opportunity
to get mini coins and that they should
split the money because they're friends
at that moment the man in the suitcase
asks them to help him and the friend
decides to go see him while justin stays
talking with his ex
who asks if this is all fake
to which justin replies that no the gold
coins are real the friend decides to
close the suitcase with a man inside and
then drag it to the stairs and throw it
causing the man to suffer a lot and as a
consequence he spits many gold coins
when the three friends see all the money
they get very excited so justin accepts
the deal and tells them that they're
going to get coins from the man but only
for 48 hours
and after that time they'll get him out
of there then they start torturing the
twisted man by putting his hand in a
mousetrap then they pull out some teeth
kick him and so on with the money he
earns justin pays the rent and also buys
new clothes while his ex buys expensive
necklaces and everyone seems very happy
with the prophets then we see that
justin's friend is betraying him with
his ex but they only show affection when
justin is not around one night the three
friends were torturing the man with an
electricity machine but they see that
the twisted man looks terrible so justin
tells his friends that maybe it's time
to stop however they want to continue
and at that moment the twisted man
replies it doesn't matter anymore since
he will surely die soon so they don't
have to worry about him justin insists
that they should stop and the friend
replies that they have almost got all
the money they've always wanted so they
continue like this they'll soon be able
to buy luxury houses boats and other
things
justin says that they had agreed that
they would only do that for 48 hours
and that time is up
so they should now help the man get out
of the suitcase justin also tells them
they should ask themselves who they want
to be to which the friend replies that
he wants to be rich and for that they
must continue then the friend tells
justin that with all that money he could
buy his dad's business and make him work
for him to which justin replies that
they are being mean and that they should
stop justin tells them that he'll call
the police but just when he was going to
do so the ex takes his cell phone and
breaks it justin gets mad at her and at
that moment the girl decides to hit
justin in the head badly injured he
decides to walk out but falls down the
stairs and ends up seriously injured on
the floor the girl asks the friend what
they should do and he replies that they
should escape with all the money they
have
but before doing so they should first
get a little more money from the twisted
man so they take the electrical device
and prepare for one last attack and at
that moment the twizzler men asked them
not to do it and he tells them that they
are very naughty children however they
decide to turn on the machine anyway
but the twisted man starts laughing and
tells them that they are very evil and
that the world should not have so much
evil
while his eyes turn yellow and bright
suddenly a lot of black smoke begins to
come out of the suitcase and then a
monster comes out with two suitcases
one for the friend and another for the
ex
later justin wakes up in a hospital and
when he looks around he finds a note
that says
get well soon at the end we see that the
twisted man goes to the airport dressed
in a suit and asked for his plane ticket
while the manager asks him how his visit
was in that city the man replies it was
very nice
and then asked him to put his bags on
the plane we see that he brings many
bags with him and we hear that there are
people inside two of them
justin's friend and ex
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best horror and bizarre
series and movies
thanks for watching